Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 13th,
2017.
What's going on?
How,
why?
Yeah.
What's going on?
I am in New York City,
bald bone,
bone butter to dote.
Um,
oh,
that's actually Hollywood with the fuck am I thinking?
It's not a New York Song,
right?
Bam,
Darryl.
It,
it did,
it did.
That's Hollywood right?
That's in New York side.
Start spreading the news.
Right.
I don't fucking know.
I'm all over the map here.
Um,
I'm winding down this trip.
I just wrapped up my acting gig on front runner.
Uh,
I want to thank everybody that,
that allowed me to be on that movie.
I had such a great time.
I met so many great people on that shoot.
And,
uh,
the last night of the shoot,
I actually got to do a scene with the star of the movie
Jackman.
And um,
I can't even tell you how great that experience was.
He might,
he might be the,
not one of the nicest guys I've ever met in my life.
Uh,
totally cool.
Big Guy too.
He's like six,
four or something.
Big Guy.
Totally cool.
Nicest fucking dude ever.
Then you start doing the scene right.
And it's his character in the scene was getting,
was getting mad and like frustrated with us dude.
And he went into that wolverine thing a little bit.
I was just like,
Jesus Christ,
I will not fuck with this guy.
Just an amazing,
amazing actor.
And uh,
I was the coolest thing like on the last night,
um,
we had like two things to shoot,
like one quick thing in a car and then the whole rest of the thing was,
uh,
us,
you know,
like me and two other actors and Hugh Jackman.
And it was just like,
it was a,
yeah,
we shot that the whole night and was one of those things where you're like,
I wouldn't really care if we continued shooting the scene tomorrow.
I'm having so much fun.
You know,
I found out,
I actually,
I like to run when I act,
this scene involves me running into running before I t I delivered the uh,
my lines or whatever and I found that I really liked that.
And I was just like,
wow,
no wonder.
I always like William Shatner and Tj Hooker.
I know I've talked about this before,
but if you ever watched TJ hooker,
I don't think in the history of television they ever,
they ever made an actor run farther than they made William Shatner who's well
into his 50s by then they would just have like this,
the master shot of the scene and I want to get all old Hollywood here on yet,
but the master is just,
when you go to shoot the scene is you're just,
it's a wide and you're capturing every character in it or you're establishing
the place,
the setting.
I have no fucking idea.
I think that's what it is.
Right?
They would just,
they would just be standing on the other side of a wharf,
a runway like William Shatner.
He chased after planes and they would just start and he would come running
around the corner and he would always be like 70 yards away and they'd be
playing this fucking music with the Bongos in the background and you would watch
him just full speed running a man in his 50s.
All right.
And this is like the 80,
so no guys stretched
unless you were on like,
you know,
you had to be like in the Olympics.
And even then if you watch like the old NFL films,
the way that they would stretch,
you know what I mean?
They weren't doing like any,
just sort of doing a forward bend,
none of that Yoga Shit.
It was like touch your toes,
touch your hips,
touching shoulders,
do a jumping jack,
come back down or whatever the fuck they would do for that type of stuff.
Um,
running and cop's shoes,
full speed for a good 80 yards.
There's actually a great youtube video that I think I posted before we have TJ
hooker running.
Um,
so anyways,
I had the,
I had the best time and uh,
did the perfect amount of time on the movie cause right when it ended I came
right here to New York and then I'm going to go back and the rest of my year,
other than like two road gigs,
I am done.
And I'm going to get to spend this ridiculous amount of quality time with my
wife and daughter and I can't wait.
I'm totally getting into the Christmas spirit this year.
Not to the point of sacrificing thanksgiving.
Um,
you know,
I don't know,
I might even put up a couple of little like cut out turkeys in my house.
I had out thanksgiving just gets passed over,
you know what I mean?
Gets passed over like a,
a,
I dunno like a person that should have got the job but didn't write,
but I'm totally getting into it.
And I am,
I'm still sober.
Was that he was 84 days on Thursdays.
So 85,
86,
87,
88.
Eric Lindros 88 Lynn Swann.
I wasn't [inaudible] 88.
Yeah.
Um,
88 days,
not Busan.
And,
uh,
I think I'm going to go for the a hundred.
I don't know.
You know,
I think I will be,
let's see,
I'll be 91 on Thursday a week from Thursday.
It'll be 98 and then there'll be thanksgiving.
And what,
I'm not going to have a little brandy and my Eggnog,
they're big with the brandy in the egg knock,
you know?
Um,
that's what I would have added to the great opie and Anthony bit the Eggnog.
Ope,
Anthony Little Jimmy.
Right.
Do you think those guys love to get back together?
Do like a reunion tour?
They should have like a one off.
You don't even like a in like the police got back together.
They should do that with great radio shows where everybody eventually,
you know,
just got sick of each other and went the other way.
But fans are still sitting there like,
come on man,
just to one more tour,
man.
They should all get together.
You know,
I think it will have guns and roses can get back together.
Right.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
plowing ahead here.
I'm totally going to get into the holidays.
Uh,
and I dunno,
I dunno about the drinking thing.
I think I'm done for awhile.
Like I said,
I want to go staying in my fifties.
I'm turning 50 in June
and um,
I want to make sure,
uh,
I dunno,
that's a critical fucking decade,
right?
That's that one.
They may,
you know,
people like fucking die in their 50s.
So I get
that
you just had some people just start dying.
I mean,
people,
I've,
Oh God,
I've already lost like I've lost count how many fucking friends I actually,
I have a list on my phone so I don't forget all the comics that I've known that
have died.
Um,
by the way,
all men,
all men out of the 25,
they're all meant,
so all these women out there,
like you don't understand how difficult it is to be a woman.
It's like,
lady,
I got 25 dead friends.
They were all guys,
okay,
I don't know what the fuck is going on with us.
But whatever you guys,
that there's something that you guys,
something in your life is easier.
I know in this age of feminism where it just has to be,
everything is so fucking much harder for a woman.
There is one easy thing,
one easier thing for a woman and it really is the most important thing and that
is staying alive.
I wouldn't fuck is my phone.
I got them all like I got and I'm probably going to forget a few people.
All right,
let's see here.
These are all the fucking people that I knew that had gone here.
All right.
It all started with Mitch Hedberg in like March I think at 2005.
Mitch Hedberg,
Freddy Soto,
Mitch Malanie,
Robert Schimmel,
Bernie Mac,
Dave Fitzgerald,
Kevin Knox,
Bob Site Bell,
Bob Lazaruth rich site slur auto from auto and George Greg Giraldo,
Patrice O'Neal,
Todd Lynn,
Sam Brown,
Charlie Murphy,
Scott Kennedy,
John Pinette,
Richard Jeni,
Mike,
DCF,
DCF these to Fano,
Ralphie may and peak coming.
Those are all the people that I knew really well our worked with as a comedian
that have all died since 2005 [inaudible] Dave Fitzgerald,
he died earlier.
He doesn't like 2001.
It was a Boston comic.
Um,
and I probably forgot a few people,
you know,
club owners,
Manny Dorman,
elution hope.
And then I have like,
let's high school kids that I went to school with.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
all guys
fucking unbelievable.
You just don't understand sometimes what it's like to be,
I know.
I absolutely,
I'm sure it's fucking a much more difficult than a lot of ways,
but I'll tell you the most important way.
Staying alive.
Let's not forget that.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so I did the,
the new west side comedy club and it was,
I just the perfect layout.
And I also love to,
it's right around the corner from the,
uh,
the beacon theater.
So,
uh,
I've gotten to play,
there are a couple of times,
but what I also love is if I was a young comedian starting out,
it's really like this motivational thing where you walk out and then you walk
around the corner and there's the beacon theater and you can kind of be
thinking,
you know,
someday,
maybe I'll be able to play that place.
That's the type of shit that used to get me.
Um,
used to get me motivated when I'm starting out,
although I don't know about playing theaters.
I think it was just seeing Caroline's comedy club because when I was starting
out,
like nobody played theaters.
It was like Cosby played theaters.
George Carlin like you had to be like a legend.
Um,
Joan Rivers,
um,
those people played like theaters and um,
you know,
for most comedians when I started,
I think it was,
um,
the dream was to just sell out clubs.
The dream was to sell our clubs and to get an a sitcom built around your act.
Uh,
that was the dream.
And then somewhere along the line it's switched.
And a lot of people talk about,
you know,
social media and blah,
blah,
Blah and all that.
I think the biggest thing that is created,
one of the big things that people forget as far as like how all of these
comedians now are,
are,
are big enough of a draw to play theaters.
I think one of the best things that happened for comedians that nobody brings up
is Napster.
An online file sharing air quotes,
sharing of music,
which was really stealing music that completely destroyed the music business and
their ability to make stars.
Um,
you remember virgin records member,
you would go in there and they had that little CD listening thing and they had
like the top 10 of the top 20 cds and they'd always be like a new band in there.
It's like they were feeding,
you know,
bring in New People in.
And once Napster came out and then it was the lime wire and all of that shit,
and then iTunes and all of that,
what happened was,
um,
oh,
am I gonna use this term?
There was an development of new,
like when you look at like the amount of bands that broke through and like the
last 10 years that was suddenly able to sell out arenas.
It's like a handful of bands or people like lady Gaga,
Bruno Mars was that 21 pilots is very few
that got that big.
Um,
at least not as much as,
uh,
as they used to.
I feel my might be completely wrong on this,
but if I'm,
if I'm not mistaken,
there was like,
like the MTV music or had like the five,
the same five artists for a long time.
We're with a few new ones but like,
like Jay z Kanye and I'm like,
I don't know,
I'm not so good with all the,
all the youngest people stuff,
but they stuck around forever at those music awards because there was not these
new people coming in.
MMM.
Usually for somebody to stick around in a music award for over 10 years,
I feel like there was only a couple of bands that could do it,
but they had to keep those people from 10 years previous cause they all got
knocked out.
And then I'm going to get to a point here.
So everything became a quick little bullshit.
I don't want to pay for it online.
And I think in everybody went online,
either wanted to fucking,
uh,
watch someone do something incredible on a skateboard,
some x games,
shit.
Or you wanted to watch people fail and you wanted to laugh.
And I feel like standup comedy fit into that set up punch,
set up,
punch.
It was quick.
They made you laugh,
you fucking moved on.
And then I think comedians slid into all of these theater gigs that were,
all of these bands would have been playing.
I'm not talking arenas,
I just mean like,
like theaters.
I might be wrong on that one,
but I think,
um,
if you look at the graph as the music business imploded,
comedy went through the fucking roof.
Then also with technology,
I'll comic comics could just keep putting out these specials and then Netflix
was another big thing.
But everybody talks about that.
But nobody seems,
I don't know.
I think the music business,
I'm completely imploding also helped out stand up.
It created a void.
Um,
I don't know you like that you'd like me discussing the fee,
the ins and outs
of ticket sales in stand up comedy.
So anyway,
so I was working at the,
uh,
west side comedy club.
You got to go there.
Some old friends of mine opened the place up.
That's why I did it.
I the best time.
And what was really cool is it mostly,
you know,
podcast listeners,
so I could say whatever the fuck I thought essentially in these times,
you know what I mean?
Everything that's going on,
you know,
I heard like those fucking people were going down to the comedy cellar and then
writing down what other comics were saying about Louis C K and all of that type
of stuff was just,
it's just so fucking,
it's such a crazy time right now.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I Love Louis C K and that was really obviously just fucking hard thing to see
happen to somebody.
And he was definitely 100% wrong.
I'll just say this,
he was 100% wrong.
He did own up to it and I think he will definitely be back.
Um,
yeah,
I will say that.
And I also knew a couple of the women that he did this shit too.
And I just feel bad for everybody.
It's just fucking terrible.
And uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what else to say about it.
I feel like I'm in a divorce where,
you know,
both the mom and the dad,
you need just,
you've got to like pick a fucking side here.
Uh,
you know,
I dunno all,
I think that just this new thing though is like,
like the level of witch hunt that happened when the Louis thing came out.
Like the amount of fucking people that they went after was just fucking,
it was like six degrees of Louise Dick,
you know,
to the point that even the fucking Huffington post was even trying to like,
list people that clients have the same manager that he had and stuff.
Who by the way is one of the great people I've ever met in life.
I stand by my fucking manager and I'm never firing the guy.
I've been with this guy since 2006 date.
Becky's one of the great people that I've met in this business.
I love that guy.
It's still have him over my house for fucking dinner watching everybody just,
Oh,
I think I remember this happening 15 fucking years ago and then watching
everybody tried to burn down this guy's life.
It's just fucking predicts people.
This is America.
You remember due process,
like the whole thing is just like,
it's fucking insane.
I wouldn't be surprised if they're going after Louis C K mailman saying if you
deliver his mail,
you're part of the problem.
Um,
you know,
and it doesn't seem to be like there's any sort of like,
in the judicial system where this,
like if you steal a bike,
you get this sentence.
If you rob a bank,
you get this.
If you kill somebody,
if you kill a whole bunch of people all the way up to the death penalty.
Yeah.
This kind of seems like it's become,
um,
it doesn't make a difference if it's sexual misconduct all the way to sexual
assault slash rape,
you know,
you're getting the exact same,
uh,
like level of punishment.
Um,
so that's only my question.
Okay.
Out of all of this,
because he was definitely wrong.
Obviously I'm betting this is all obvious shit that I'm saying,
but uh,
does the punishment matched the crime because you know,
sexual misconduct and you talk about sexual misconduct?
Like I,
I don't,
I would,
I don't know how many podcasts I would have to do to tell you all the stories of
sexual misconduct with just women as a standup comedian who used to go out after
his shows,
selling his posters all and taken pictures
with just the fucking women.
Okay.
And I'll tell you,
it was never any of the young ones.
It was always these middle aged fucking women.
Couple of glasses of red wine.
Oh God.
And they'd come at you with their Vava boom energy and you'd be like,
oh no,
here we go.
You know,
that's my advice.
Young male comics out there,
young female comics is plenty of information out there for you now about
watching out for creepy guys.
But I don't think there's anything out there for young male comics.
I will tell you this,
okay,
if you're going to go out and meet a crowd afterwards,
when middle aged women,
you can tell they've had too much wine beyond the fact that they sort of
teetering on their high heel shoes with their old feet sticking out of them,
just looked for the gray teeth.
All right.
And a little bit too much makeup and then you know,
they got the girls out a little bit.
Just fucking watch yourself.
Okay.
Cause that's the,
uh,
that's the old cheerleader who is not aging well and is freaking out that guys
don't,
you know,
find her attractive anymore and I'm telling you,
they're going to come up to you,
you know,
Covey.
A junk.
That's all I'm going to say.
Dude.
I had a woman licked my neck one time and I'll tell you worse than the touch of
her tongue,
her old ass disgusting wine breath tongue on my fucking neck.
Worse than that was,
I felt her breath right before the eagle landed.
I will,
ugh.
Oh Gee.
Oh and forget about gay guys.
Jesus Christ.
I got to do another half podcast on that one.
We were just talking about sexual misconduct.
Um,
I always wanted to rub your chest.
The fuck did you just do,
I remember one time,
this is the thing about a guy,
when it happens to a guy,
it's just funny just for the simple fact that,
you know,
generally speaking,
you can overpower whoever the fuck is coming at Ya.
I'm not a,
I'm not a little boy.
So I get why nobody gives a shit when this happens to a guy,
I get it.
Um,
I remember I was dating this absolutely lovely woman,
beautiful woman.
She danced on Broadway.
She was such a sweet out.
I loved him to death and I completely fucked it up cause I was an angry young
man,
so I'm sorry to her.
Right.
So she was dancing in this thing,
um,
called Broadway bears,
which was like,
they used to do this thing to raise money.
It was like a burlesque show.
So it wasn't like this creepy titty bar thing.
It was just,
uh,
you know,
if you ever go to a burlesque show,
which my wife took me to one to see that Dita von Teese.
I was just like,
are you fucking kidding me?
She's going to take me down here to go to go see,
basically go do a rated PG 13 strip club.
I have the coolest wife ever.
And then I got down there and I think I was the only straight guy there and it
was like mostly
gay guys.
Right.
And uh,
that's what this Broadway bears thing was that it wasn't like the creepy who's
five.
So it's actually better if there's a bunch of gay dudes there.
Cause I always did that whole,
I like holders,
strip clubs,
titty bars and all that shit.
It's just like,
that's something that's like fascinating when you're like in your twenties I
think.
And then somewhere,
you know,
if you're progressing,
if you're maturing at some point it just becomes gross.
Or at the very least like this is fucking stupid.
You know,
I want to go out and get laid.
I'm going to sit here looking at naked women who aren't gonna fuck me.
You know,
this is stupid while losing a ton of money,
paying for watered down drinks.
What now I don't want to eat it here.
You're in the sex industry.
Get away from me.
I want to order some food,
right?
So I go down to this Broadway bears thing,
And uh,
you know,
there's all these fucking lyrics.
There's all these smoking hot women doing their dances and stuff.
And then there's all these shredded dudes.
So all the gay guys that go nuts about the dude's,
and I'm looking at all these women going like,
oh my God,
right?
Fucking dancer legs.
They were incredible.
Right?
Oh,
by the way,
they also were really talented.
All right,
so the fucking show ends
and I'm waiting for my girlfriend at the time to come out and this fucking out
of nowhere,
this guy came up and just smacked me on the ass.
And it wasn't like,
like,
it was like if you were playing football,
it was good game,
but at that place it wasn't.
This guy wanted to fucking hook up.
Dude,
he hit me so hard,
like I almost fucking got whiplash and I fucking turned around and I can't say
what I said to the guy.
Um,
but I made it clear to him that I wasn't gay and I'll never forget,
he just like put his hands up and was like backing away.
I remember when he put his hands up like,
dude at these fucking guns.
And I was just like,
you know,
I don't know what this guy's thinking right now,
but if he wanted to do something,
I don't know if there's anything I could do about it.
I'll never forget is,
is big hairy gay arms just coming out?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I just fuck no,
you didn't even talk like that.
I'm doing like the hacky gave voice.
He had just like a regular dude voice and um,
oh,
do I get a zillion of those fucking zillion of those fucking stories if we're
talking sexual misconduct here and um,
and you know,
it's funny is the reason I stopped going out after my shows wasn't all of those
fucking witches of Eastwick drunk bitches coming up to me doing God knows what,
right.
Just crossing all kinds of fucking lines.
Like literally like you're a cartoon character.
What made me finally stop was that time that guy went to take the camera to take
the picture of his girlfriend or wife and a loaded nine millimeter fell on
fucking proud.
Yeah.
And it was right on the ground and I should have kicked it away.
You know,
all the episodes is staff eight Hutch.
I watched,
I didn't,
I just froze.
I pointed at the gun,
I went,
Dude,
what the fuck?
And I let them bend down and pick it up.
And I just stood there.
I've never felt more white in my life,
you know what I mean?
Just classic Culdesac like a,
Hey Frank d,
I believe you dropped your pistol.
Thanks.
Bell blows my fucking brains out.
Oh,
you hear that?
That's my alarm.
I get up a little early.
So anyways,
people,
uh,
I think it's a great thing that all of this stuff is coming out because there's
no way that women should have to be tolerating this.
They've tolerated it way too long.
But can we stop short here of like,
um,
then trying to literally destroy everybody around the fucking person.
MMM.
Over social media and no burden of proof whatsoever.
These are like real people that should going after,
okay.
You know,
these people that are around these people that have done horrible things.
They have wives,
they have kids,
they have families,
they have mortgages,
you know,
and just to just fucking,
just Willy Nilly,
oh,
somebody just said this on Twitter.
It has to be true and just pile on and blow on the ashes and try to turn it into
fuck a fucking inferno.
MMM.
It's is also not right.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I feel really bad for my manager and what the hell he's going through right now.
I really do.
MMM.
And I'm not going to be one of these fucking people and I hate how this,
this whole fucking day.
And it don't say anything,
man.
It's not worth it.
Don't say things.
So I'm just going to lead this guy who's been a friend to me for fucking 11
years,
guided me through my career,
my career,
went through the fucking stratosphere with this guy.
I'm just going to leave.
I'm twisting in the wind.
Go Fuck Yourself.
They'd,
Becky's a great guy.
MMM.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
What do we got here?
Uh,
but Buh,
Buh,
Buh Buh.
Let's read a little bit.
Uh,
no,
I,
you know what I missed,
I missed the,
uh,
I missed the Formula One race in it sounded like it was amazing evidence.
I don't know how Lewis Hamilton ended up,
uh,
starting in last place,
but he worked his way all the way up to first,
which I have never seen somebody must've crashed
because,
uh,
I dunno the way Max for staffing was running during the last race.
Once somebody gets out in front of,
you know,
when they're driving through the clean air,
there was that little thing I know about aerodynamics and racing.
No one can never catch himself.
They must've had a brilliant strategy plus like slash somebody else that was
plush plus and slash plash.
Um,
somebody's car must have broken down or uh,
they must've been an accident or something.
I have no idea.
But,
uh,
can somebody say,
I know you guys have sent me this link before.
Can somebody try and find a,
or send me the link to where,
um,
where I can rewatch the races.
Um,
the replay of Brazil's a grant.
What did you see?
Fucking the Mercedes Benz team got robbed at gunpoint.
Lewis Hamilton wasn't there and,
but he's quote was basically this happens every time we come down here.
How bad is that for tourism in Brazil?
You know what I mean?
Every time we come down here,
the Illuminati sport gets fucking robbed.
Can we do something about security?
Um,
you know,
thank God.
Like,
you know,
I,
if I was like the president of Brazil,
I actually wouldn't be too nervous because Brazil has arguably the most
beautiful women in the world down there.
You know what I mean?
And that will keep people coming despite the fact that even the Mercedes Benz
Formula One team gets robbed at gunpoint and they weren't there on vacation.
They came down there with the entire sport and somebody still finally got
through.
I guess when you got a pistol,
you don't really need a laminate.
The,
uh,
can we see your credentials?
Yeah,
yeah.
Right here,
buddy.
Okay.
Lewis Hamilton saw over there and I believe he's still has his diamond earring
it have at it.
Um,
all right,
let's read a,
let's read some,
uh,
some advertising here for this week.
Saucy.
Everybody thought the,
um,
everyone at some point has which wish they could have just have a beer,
wine or liquor delivered while someone finally decided to do something about it.
Next,
please mention all the talking points below.
Introducing Southie.
The,
the alcohol delivery APP.
Saucy delivers your favorite wine,
be liquor right to you do and no more.
No more demand.
It's Uber for alcohol.
Now,
if you're in Los Angeles now,
if you're in Los Angeles,
San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego or Sacramento,
you're saucy order will arrive at your door in 30 minutes or less,
ready to drink for the rest of us.
Saucy,
we'll deliver beer,
wine,
and liquor to your door in two days or less.
Nationwide,
there are no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
See if you've got a party coming up,
right?
Your parents are going out of town,
You're going to have a gig.
You're going to have a blowout,
right?
You can call these people up.
If you've got the saucy APP,
you've got a fully stocked bar right in your phone.
And for a limited time you can get $15 off.
Uh,
when you download the saucy APP and enter the Promo Code Bird,
that saucy APP,
spelled saucy,
Sau,
Cya,
and enter Promo code bar for $15 off.
Get the saucy app today and use Promo Code Burn.
Ah,
look who's back everybody.
Low bag moto to beyond the ego.
Beyond the why did you lick my neck to,
to the beyond days me on days.
But I'm a get part of,
I'm a guy.
So what the heck does a fucking count if you have a deck?
So if you grabbed my junk really quick,
you're not going to jail in your,
all your shit will still be on fucking HBO.
Bah,
Bah Bah Bah booboo.
All right,
let me tell you about me undies.
The only underwear,
this is the only one to wear that makes for an amazing gift.
Uh,
feel free to improvise.
Um,
Jesus Christ a soft,
that's what they just wrote there.
Talk about why you love me undies.
You know I love me on these cause I love singing this song.
That's why plus I evidently,
they're also so soft,
flexible waistband,
three times softer than cotton.
Cotton just takes a beating during these,
these,
these fucking,
you know,
these reeds,
they're always getting trashed.
I'm waiting for them to have like an answer song.
You know,
on naturally sustainable sourced fiber.
Mandy's has made me undies made underwear.
The perfect gift that everyone is going to love you for.
It's a great stocking stuffer.
It's a Goddamn holiday miracle this year.
Don't give underwear.
Give me undies this holiday season and get your exclusive 20% off the softest
underwear and socks you'll ever wear.
Free Shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to me undies.com/ [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr.
All right,
dollar shave club.
Um,
as soon as I heard dollar shave club had stuff other than their razors,
I was sold evidently.
Why do they always try to write what I'm thinking?
All right.
I actually think that they're really smart.
Like why stop there?
They get it.
Guys want to shit,
shower and shave and they're giving them everything to do it,
but with it right at the store there are too many options and you can't tell the
difference between any of them.
Then if you have any questions,
the clerk usually doesn't know the difference either or can't really help you.
Since they are not experts on products just like their razors,
everything is super high quality and left me looking and feeling amazing
evidently from premium ingredients to sophisticated fence,
sophisticated sense.
You know like before you put it on everybody thinks you're a moron and all of a
sudden you put on their fucking body spray though.
Did you go to Grad School?
Dollar Shave Club is changing the game status set to new members for only $5 to
start a set features there.
Ix,
executive razor and three trial size versions of their most popular products
that help you stay fresh and clean.
And your first box you received this shave butter bodywash and one wipe
Jahrese but wipes.
Oh Chari uh,
you will also receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium,
weighty handle and focus set of cartridges.
By the way,
when you get a razor that as a weighty handle,
do not pull it down and drag it across your face,
okay?
You just let it,
you just lightly hold it and you let gravity pull it down across your face.
That's,
that's the way you do it.
All right.
Trust me,
if you do it the other way,
you're going to cut your face if you do it the way I just said,
you're going to get the smoothest shave you have and your life after the first
box replacement cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a month.
This offer is exclusively available@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar.
Uh,
that's dollar shave club.com/burr.
And if you want a great gift,
Give Them Dollar Shave Club.
They've got a super simple gift membership and egift cards,
dollar shave club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There is no better time to try the club.
Oh and stamps.com everybody.
Lastly,
but certainly not leastly stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
You can mail any letter in any package just using your computer,
a printer and the mailman comes and picks it up.
Avoid the hassle,
man of the post office and mail everything from post office.
Uh,
some postcards to envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your own convenience.
24,
seven.
Um,
it's convenient.
It's easy,
it's reliable,
it's flexible,
right?
Just like that cool chick up the street that doesn't want to be in a
relationship.
I use stamps.com because anytime I send out my fucking posters,
you know,
and I want to go out there and be a,
I have some sexual misconduct with some women who are far too old to be acting
in that way.
I send them out
through stamps.com dude,
I've actually been telling his story of by the letter of the law is something
that happened to me last year,
which was sexual assault,
which was by a woman,
but it's a lady,
so no one gives a shit.
Um,
I've come out and see my fucking standup set.
There you go.
I'm teasing sexual assault here.
I'm just turning it into a bit.
Um,
uh,
yeah,
and it's a really funny fucking story.
Um,
but by the letter of the law,
it is sexual assault.
Um,
you know,
and where's my 15 minutes of fame?
And right now you too can enjoy stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Without a long longterm commitments,
go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirthatstamps.com stamps.com never go to
the post office again.
All right,
what are we up to here?
35 minutes.
All right.
So the f one of the other two reasons why I'm here in New York.
Okay.
Reasons I
did the west side comedy club,
Bam.
A on Saturday night I did a Michael J.
Fox is charity.
The uh,
the Fox Foundation.
I did a benefit for them.
One of the coolest gigs I've ever got to do in my life.
I,
uh,
I show up,
right?
First of all,
it's Michael J.
Fox,
right?
I mean that guy's comedic timing.
You know,
like when they say somebody has like a perfect pitch when they go to sing or
whatever.
I always felt like,
you know,
grew up watching him on family ties and of course all the back to the future
movies.
Um,
and I just piss,
timing was just like,
was impeccable.
Right?
And it makes it really,
really easy.
But just as a fan of comedy and everything,
I always loved the guy.
So I,
I realized I was going to get to meet him and I show up to the Gig and I'm
always nervous whenever I have to do a benefit cause it's,
you know,
it's a benefit.
People are going to be in this,
you know,
they're going to be in a certain mindset or it's just like,
wow,
I'm really lucky that you know,
I'm healthy,
I have my family,
blah blah,
blah,
and other,
these other people are going through this really difficult thing.
These are,
there's a sense of like guilt that you feel,
um,
just all of that type.
It just puts the crowd in a certain mood where then all of a sudden they go from
laughing to everything that you say is just like,
ah,
oh Bo,
you know,
those are the sounds I usually here at benefits.
So I was,
I'm always a little apprehensive and in my head I'm sitting there going like,
alright,
how can I navigate this situation?
Cause there's what I want to talk about.
And then there's what I should talk about just to get through this.
Right?
So I show up in the front of the first people I saw was Eugene Mirman who hadn't
seen in awhile and I was so relieved to see another comedian.
I was just like,
oh,
thank God.
So we both would just sort of laugh and talking about how,
all right,
it's a benefit.
How is this?
What's going to happen?
How is this one gonna go down?
Hopefully this is going to be good.
And as I was talking to him,
I heard this amazing band playing in the background was like,
it sounded so good.
I'm like,
is that live?
That's unreal.
But we were back in the green room.
I was like,
I got to check them out and raise.
I went to go out this like guy comes walking by and goes,
hey bill burr.
I don't.
He was like,
ah,
you know,
I've seen your stuff man.
You funny.
And I said,
oh,
thanks a lot.
I appreciate it.
I go,
look at you,
you're addressed all sharp.
I'm like,
are you going up tonight?
He goes,
yeah.
I go,
what do you,
what do you do?
You're a comedian.
Egos die.
Cause I play a little guitar,
you know,
I love musicians.
I'm like,
Holy Shit Man.
You play in a band.
That's fucking great.
Right?
It turned out that guy was Brad Paisley.
I'm old.
I don't know who the kids are.
Right.
I have no fucking idea.
He went on in the end and was one of the greatest entertainers I've seen in a
long fucking time.
APPS.
He goes,
I play a little guitar,
right?
Shreds.
Absolutely shreds on guitar.
Amazing voice.
I said to him after,
cause I felt like an asshole that I didn't know who he was,
but I'm also,
I'm old.
You know what I mean?
We 50 next year,
right?
I loved,
and I'm loving turning 50.
Now.
This is when you start to have excuses.
I'm 50,
I don't know things.
Um,
I said to him,
I seen you,
I love about you country guys.
All you guys get can play.
You know,
I'm not into all the country music,
but they can,
they can fucking play and they can sing.
And it reminds me of hair metal.
As much as people trashed me for listening to that,
those guys could play and they could sing.
They could,
they could do it live.
We'll do it lot.
Fuck it.
Right?
So anyways,
I'm hearing all this band.
So I,
uh,
I go,
I gotta go check these guys out.
Right.
I thought the third song or heard.
So I go to walk out there
to see the,
um,
to see the band playing and I looked at it and I'm looking at the drummer,
this is giant like,
you know,
banquet hall room and I'm just looking at the drummer and I just fucking staring
at him for like five seconds of disbelief.
And I look at the woman next to me who was working for the foundation.
I was like,
is that Steve Jordan?
She goes,
yeah.
He's like really good.
I'm like,
really good.
He's one of the greatest fucking drummers of all time.
This is like a bucket list for me to ever see this guy play live.
I can't,
I couldn't believe it.
My jaw was on the ground.
Like you gotta understand like I,
I've been listening to Steve Jordan since like,
I guess when I first started watching Letterman and I didn't even realize at
that point that he played on those blues brothers albums.
Then I discovered those,
I even bought the second blues brothers album made in America.
And then nobody bought.
I have all of that shit.
All of his Keith Richards expensive.
Why?
No Shit.
I watched him on the leg with the Letterman band.
Um,
I go on youtube,
there's a fusion album that he put out
the fuck was the name of that band that you can't find.
I can't find the album anywhere where he's really young.
Um,
plan on,
on that one a way busier than he,
he plays on a lot of other stuff,
right through all the John Mayer stuff.
And I was always thinking,
okay,
when John Mayer comes to town with his trio,
I'm definitely gonna go see that.
And I'll finally get to see Steve Jordan playing live,
you know,
switching out the snares and all of that,
that whole,
all that hope.
That's his whole thing that he does that.
It's just so incredible.
But every time John Mayor would come to la,
I would always be on the road and I'd always miss it.
So I actually got to see him play.
And,
um,
so anyways,
I'm sitting there and at the banquet thing and I meet Michael J.
Fox and he's just like the nicest guy ever.
Him and his wife,
just a couple of sweethearts,
you know,
just one of those amazing couples too,
both good looking people and then they,
they,
they formed,
when they get together they form an even more amazing person,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm sitting there and like,
I'm literally nervous.
Like I'm a brand new.
Whenever I get,
whenever I do benefits,
I get like that nervous cause like I've,
I've had some that have not gone well.
I've done some Christmas parties.
The reason why I don't do Christmas parties,
I don't do private gigs,
you know,
which are basically rich people or rich companies or something,
uh,
get to together and they will literally hire anyone from like fucking you too,
all the way down to some no name comic.
Like I was back when I used to do those fucking things and you would go up there
and nobody would know that there was a show and the Dick omic bless the one I
did.
Yeah.
Like they had me go up.
It was in like a restaurant in these people had rented out the restaurant and
everybody was eating and talking and I went up there and I was,
no one was listening and I got defensive.
So my already angry material back then.
It was coming off even angrier and people just literally stopped eating or just
sort of staring down at their plates.
And um,
I tried every trick that I knew in the book to turn it around and I couldn't do
it and I just fucking bombed.
I ruined their dinner.
I ruined,
they're not at least that part of it.
And I just walked out of there with my agent at the time
and God bless him,
he had to listen to me walk 12 blocks with them with absolutely absolute
Tourette's,
just going like,
I am never fucking doing one of those fucking things again.
Who the fuck bring somebody up when everybody's fucking everyday like I did
that.
I was going,
Casey case him and I was supposed to go on and talk about a fuck a dog die in,
right.
I went into that mode,
you know,
but by the end,
after 12 blocks,
I,
by the end of it,
we were both laughing and I was just like,
should we give them their money back?
You know,
that was like,
fuck,
I feel bad,
but this is the real reason why I was flipping out.
You know,
I was embarrassed.
And then I also felt like I stole money cause I just wasn't,
I wasn't the guy for that Gig.
It should have been like somebody like a who was happy with themselves.
All right.
So anyways,
let's get on with the,
uh,
not off.
I'll finish telling the story.
So anyways,
uh,
fortunately the great Dennis leary was,
was hosting this event and he went up and immediately turns it into a comedy
show,
you know,
he was up there doing what he does and he dropped,
a couple of f bombs.
And then with every joke he told,
I got more and more and more and more relaxed.
And I was like,
ah,
thank God.
And then,
uh,
I went up on stage and I just,
I just fucking went off and,
uh,
yeah,
told all these.
I just,
I,
I dunno,
I did all those stories telling all those fucking stories of all shit that women
have done to me.
And at first people didn't want to laugh and then they just started laughing
cause you know,
sexual misconduct,
like I said to a guy,
I'm,
and I'm agreeing with this.
It's kind of funny.
It's not right,
but it is,
it's funny.
MMM.
And at first they were like,
what the fuck?
And then they just sort of went with it and then all the rest of my shit just
flowed.
And I ended up having one of my favorite sets I've had in such a long time.
And then in the end I got to watch,
uh,
this new great musician that I did,
wasn't aware of Brad Paisley playing with Steve Jordan's band.
And um,
and then in the end they brought Michael J.
Fox out and they all played Johnny be good.
I mean,
it was just,
it was,
I was,
I was just standing there like going,
how to fuck is this?
My life was amazing.
Um,
then I just end up having,
then it just turned out it was also the New York comedy festival.
So all these guys were in town.
I got to run into brand Brian Regan who just played Carnegie Hall hanging out
with him.
I just had like the best.
I had the best fucking night and uh,
and the Great New York run here continues where tomorrow I'm going to be on
inside the NFL.
I don't know what I'm going to be talking about.
God knows I haven't watched nearly as much NFL football as I would've liked this
year.
I just got so busy with the cartoon,
my little acting Gig there.
Oh,
Bill,
what do you think?
You're an actor now.
Every once in a while I am.
Um,
all right,
my screen went dark here.
Let's type in the fucking pass where the password.
Um,
all right,
let's,
uh,
let's read some of your questions here.
All right.
Not enough women or gays at the cellar table.
Oh boy.
Here we go.
Oh,
read Dick Billy.
All the controversy in stand up comedy.
He goes,
I was hoping to get your take on an article I came across on Facebook called
tear down the boys club that protected Louis C K that set witch hunt thing that
I'm saying like we had fucking meetings every week.
All right.
What am I going to do here is say,
hey mom,
I'm going to find are you know,
and how everybody else,
the second that God,
evidently everybody else on the other side,
the second that Gawker article came out,
you know,
immediately took a criminal justice course and just became some gum shoe and
went out and bought a giant magnifying glass and walked around looking for
clues.
All right.
It's written by a gay comic who figures basically going after Louis wasn't
enough.
So he is trying to go after his peers also.
Yeah.
The which on a,
the author cries about a certain table at the comedy cellar where elite comics,
like Chris Rock and Jerry Seinfeld sit.
MMM.
Like when the table came about,
by the way,
Jerry Seinfeld was still doing Seinfeld.
You know what I mean?
I don't know if they actually had a place called the table.
MMM.
When
I first started going to the comedy cellar,
there wasn't a table.
Comics just went upstairs and they sat all over the place and I am convinced
that the reason why the table was started was because of Patrice,
because portrays was so loud and so funny and he was just all over the upstairs.
They were trying to somehow contain him.
He was like,
Jordan,
you know,
you're not going to stop them.
Let's just see if we can contain them.
So I think they just tried to get us all in,
sit,
sit it in one seated in one area so they could at least be like,
okay,
sit down and fold your fucking hands and listen to the teacher.
Right.
Um,
that's how I remembered.
Anyways,
so he goes,
he also has never even tried to perform at the co at the cellar himself.
It's kind of like a fourth grader crying to the teacher because the cool kids
won't hang out with them.
The article implies that by not speaking up about it,
the sell a comics were somehow protecting Louis even though they were just
rumors until recently.
Also the owner of the cellar,
where are we fucking screaming at dark.
Sorry,
I'll see you on his cell.
I had some great things to say in the comments.
Here's the link to the article and go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
I read it.
And um,
you know,
to be honest with you,
considering this guy,
he's also a fellow comedian.
I feel bad that that was his perception.
I feel filled yet that that was his perception of what the table was because um,
you know,
the table was like,
uh,
and I didn't even know how to explain it.
Like that was something like the level of pounding that you had to take.
You had to go there and just basically get ripped to shreds and then what
everybody at the table wanting to do.
And it wasn't even,
it wasn't doing it to just be mean.
It was just,
I don't,
it was just this comedian thing.
So you'd sit down and like you already,
you'd sit down with like whatever you were hung up about with the itself and
they would give another 40 things about you physically that you didn't even
notice,
that you should also be self conscious about.
However,
in the end,
all they wanted you to do was come back at them and trash him back.
And if you did urn regardless,
all right.
And there was some epic fucking
back and forths at that table,
you know,
and people definitely got mad sometimes,
but,
uh,
the table wasn't like what a lot of people who didn't go to it think it was like
this big bullying thing.
It was also this amazing thing where like,
uh,
I listened to Jewish people and Arab comics going at it,
talking about the Middle East.
I'd listened to Patrice and,
uh,
you know,
Manny dwarven,
um,
their debates,
calling Quinn was there and if I remember correctly,
tough crowd came out of those conversations at the table.
And if you watched tough crowd,
it'd be these comedians talking about these deep issues trashing each other.
And,
um,
I always felt that the table was inclusive.
As long as you are willing,
you had to,
you had to fucking walk the gauntlet,
you just had to fucking do and you had to survive it.
MMM.
And then if you did,
you actually became a better comedian because once you got in at the table,
then there was this thing,
you could not sit at the table.
You'd come in and be,
hey bill,
come when they wanted you to sit the table because they wanted you to trash you.
And then they also wanted you to trash him back.
But you know,
I wasn't even part of the elite crew.
I wasn't funny enough.
I just wasn't the,
like the,
the,
as far as,
this is just my,
my perception of it was the table was
Patrice Norton Vos,
Keith Robinson,
Collin Quinn,
a later on,
Kevin Hart,
Kevin Hart.
Right.
And even he was sort of like a,
just like a rookie,
but he also made it so fast and he didn't have time to fucking stay there.
So,
um,
those were the,
that was like the Mount Rushmore of the table.
And when you showed up and they will all there and somebody had something on you
like that time,
you know,
I for 24 hours set,
I would do the stand up on a bus on the weight of a world series game to get a
world series ticket.
And I never even ended up doing the Gig.
I took a headlining set pounding that is still legendary.
They told the fucking story on um,
opie and Anthony,
I believe Kevin Hart and them all told this story,
man,
I got fucking destroyed,
destroyed.
So this guy like suggesting that it was all,
like everybody was like,
there was this team of people,
it wasn't,
it was fucking cannibalistic.
All right.
Everything that they said,
an opening Anthea was 100% true except for the fact that I did the Gig because I
didn't do the Gig.
I actually gave the Gig to somebody else and I w with a vow of silence.
I said,
I will never tell anybody that you did this gig because I don't want you to go
through what I just went through.
MMM.
I think the guy who did the Gig actually might've said that he was the one who
did the Gig all these years later.
But I still am not saying shit who it was.
So anyways,
once you got in at the table then you would go downstairs to go do your set and
one night they,
everybody at the table be like,
you know what we're watching you set tonight.
And you'd be like,
Oh fuck.
And you would go downstairs,
you'd go on stage and the crowd couldn't see all these fucking asshole comics.
I remember they'd be all be backlit standing in the hallway.
Patrice is big,
dumb,
stupid head and you'd have to go up there and like just commit to your jokes as
they will all stand in there making faces of disgust,
heckling making noises.
And one time I told that joke and it went good.
And as I was telling the joke,
I had the nerve to actually try to say something in a joke and Patrice would
just go,
just do that fucking noise.
And then they would all crack up laughing.
Then the crowd would laugh like,
what the fuck?
And get a sense of like other comics are laughing at this guy,
should we be laughing at him and not respect him as a human being?
And then you would just start bombing and never forget.
I remember Kevin Hart went down stairs and he went up as a 20 year old comic and
survived it and was barely affected.
I mean,
I know.
And then looking at all this stuff that he's doing now,
like you really saw what he was made up.
It was a great thing.
The seller table is not what this person perceived it to be.
And I feel bad that that person,
because having a fed gig guy comic,
that would have been great.
That would've been a whole other angle.
It was actually a really inclusive thing.
It's just a lot of people weren't tough enough to get through it.
And that's the truth.
And it took me,
like I said,
like a half dozen attempts because I was not a mentally strong person back then.
And,
um,
but if you see what came out of it,
Colin Quinn's tough crowd,
that was one of the most inclusive shows of all time as far as like,
he gave almost like two and a half generations of standup comics,
a TV credit,
a lot of them,
their first TV credit.
Yeah.
MMM.
So I don't know.
And I'm now at,
someone's going to sit down and watch tough,
probably who's mainly white males will blah,
blah,
Blah and all that fucking shit.
So I don't know,
there's no way to win this type of stuff,
but um,
I can tell you that I don't agree with this person's perception of it,
but I don't have any anger towards that person for writing that if that's what
they feel,
think it was.
But,
uh,
it's a little melodramatic burn the table down like this,
these meetings going on and we're all sitting there trying to hold back his,
his career or whatever.
I mean I don't,
I don't fucking,
I'll remember as far as like Trans Comics,
I just remembered there was,
I don't know what the proper term was,
but there was a guy who dresses like a woman and went on stage and went by the
name.
She went by the name of Sharon needles
and she used to go up at the Boston comedy club and she was fucking hilarious.
And the last time I looked her up,
I believe she was still doing shows.
I think she just got out of the standup scene.
But nobody,
I don't know.
There's no comics
going good.
What the fuck is this fucking person doing here?
Like this all comic,
Oh,
comedy is is if you're fucking funny.
Other comics that are going to laugh and you get their respect in your in.
MMM.
Uh,
you know,
everybody has a different fucking road,
but everybody's just sitting there going like,
just,
I dunno what,
what there,
it's,
everybody's looking out their own head and it becomes,
their experience is fact in truth in anybody else's experience is bullshit or
something like that.
So all I'm doing here is I'm telling my of,
that's how I perceived it.
And,
um,
I just remember for the longest time,
like we would,
I'm a one night we fucking were outside the comedy cellar.
We trashed each other for so fucking long.
And it was so god damn funny,
it was so late in the night that this woman in an apartment above the comedy
cellar poured water down onto us to get us to shut the fuck up.
And,
uh,
going back,
you know,
like a lot of moments like that in life.
I wish I could have,
um,
I wish I could have realized how amazing that was during that time.
Cause that's as far as I was concerned,
that table,
this,
this table that this guy wants to burn down.
That died.
The table died when Manny died because,
you know,
he was the creator of it.
And,
um,
he was the,
one of the great conversationalists that I ever met and he was so God damn
funny.
And,
um,
and what I loved the bottom is he wasn't a malicious guy as much as I got,
I used to fucking argue with that guy.
You know what I mean?
I was just,
I was a young,
angry man and I used to argue with that guy and,
and he was always the next day it was always over.
And I actually kind of learned from him,
I learned from him and Bobby Kelly how to squash in argument where like how
you'd be like the next day just,
you know,
cause I didn't grow up in a family like that.
It was just basically you didn't talk about it and then you didn't talk for
three days and then fucking four days later you'd say,
Hey,
you see the cell just giving us a good,
good,
good.
And then everything was lingering.
Um,
those two people,
I learned how to have a functional end to an argument.
So,
um,
yeah,
I dunno what that Shit's about,
but it's unfortunate that that person feels that way about it,
but you know,
everybody's entitled to their opinion.
All right.
Uh,
Patrice,
a Billy Ray,
no fun.
Um,
after hearing you along with so many other comics,
universally laud Patrice,
I finally watched elephant in the room special.
Uh,
within minutes he had me in stitches.
It's so easy to see why he was so revered within the comedy community.
I know you hold him both as a comedian,
as a person person,
and an incredibly high regard.
I would love to hear some of your insight into him.
I recently heard that he was permanently banned from performing at the stand in
New York.
What was that about?
No,
he was never banned from the stand.
The stand
and the stand came out or opened right around when Patrice got sick.
Um,
he wasn't banned from there anyways,
really big fan of the show and we'd love to see come to Australia against soon.
Um,
yeah,
know Patrice,
Patrice was getting banned from comedy clubs all the time.
All the time,
but he was so fucking good.
They had to let him back in.
Uh,
it reminds of when I read this does miles Davis Book and he was talking about
Charlie Parker and when he would party to much and pawn his horn.
And these clubs would kick them out.
They'd eventually have to fucking bring them back in because he was the best and
Patrice was the best.
And you know,
as much as he would drive them nuts,
you wanted them around,
you wanted them around you.
It's like the,
like the comedy dropped by 40%,
even with all the other comics still go in there if he wasn't there.
And just the fun.
And then they also knew that if they banned him,
that none of the comics were going to hang out at the clubs.
We were all going to go to where he was.
Um,
yeah.
So then they would let them back into the club.
Yeah.
And then they created the table.
That's how I remember it.
That's how I thought that they,
let's,
we'll have them all these fucking loan it takes,
just have him sit in the back at the goddamn table.
So then we was sitting down and it just,
you know,
it's just a bunch of dogs in a fucking pit.
And then that's how the trash in the trash can was already happening.
I remember one night,
you know,
after I took the pound in for fucking the bus Gig that I never even did.
I remember when Bobby first shaved his head,
he came in and I always respected him for this.
He came in,
he had like a hat on and he sat down right at the fuck and the fat gay Guy Comic
here,
listen to this story.
He didn't shy away from the table.
He fucking walked right in,
sat down,
took his hat off and looked at everybody like,
all right,
give it to me.
Let's say it and fucking everybody just looks like a def jam.
Betty took his hat off and everybody does La have you?
What the fuck?
He took this fucking pounding and everyone was getting them and he was just
sitting there taking it laughing and all that type of stuff.
And I actually thought he looked good with the shaved head.
Right.
And um,
what's his face?
Uh,
Oh,
who said it?
I think it was SDSD finally got him with one.
I think she said you look like David Wells.
I think that that's what she said.
And everybody fucking died laughing.
And Bobby literally just stood up and just walked out.
And I remember thinking like,
you could,
I didn't know you could do that.
I don't know.
You can block out.
I saw Keith Robinson do that one time too.
We would trash in his clothes so fucking bad.
It was gay and he was trying to fight back and he was just feeling that way,
was going to crash over him.
He just fucking ran out the door,
got in his car and drove home to Jersey.
We,
we kept texting him and calling him go,
and you can't do that.
You can't do that.
He like,
Oh yeah.
Well I just did stupid fucking hung up on is laughed and hung up on us.
Um,
oh my God.
I remember that the fucking time Patrice,
you know,
somehow we found out he,
he,
he was home on a Saturday night.
He just took like a night off and uh,
Jim Norton fucking came in and said,
you know where Patrice is right now?
He said home on a Saturday night and they all called him up and on speakerphone.
Patrice just picks up.
He's like,
hello.
And Jim's like,
what the fuck are you doing home on a Saturday night?
You don't have any gigs.
And Patrice just fucking roared laughing and we all over speaker phone trashed
him.
He was at home getting trashed at the table and I just remember him law.
He loved every fucking second of it.
It was at the table is one of the great things ever.
So you know,
don't listen to that guy.
All right.
I lied to my girlfriend.
Um,
all right.
I lied to my girlfriend.
Hey Bill.
I really could use some advice right now I'm an 18 year old male and I have been
with this girl for seven months now.
I really care about her and she makes me truly happy.
About a year ago I used to smoke weed and do some drugs,
other drugs a lot.
Uh,
I used to smoke about three or four times a week,
but I quit a little under a year ago.
My girlfriend is really against drug use and has told me that she would leave me
if I ever did it again.
Well,
a couple months ago,
me and my girl were kind of on a break,
not because we don't want to be with each other,
but because of some other shit going on in our lives.
All right.
That's pretty vague.
A while we were on this break,
I smoked some weed with a buddy of mine.
Um,
I really regret doing so because I know how this is.
This means a lot to her.
Um,
she is later asked me when was the last time I did any drugs and I just lied and
told her the last time was when I told her I quit.
I can't stop thinking about this and I feel really bad about lying to her,
but I am afraid she's going to leave me or stop trusting me if I tell her now,
since I had already lied about it several times in the past.
Um,
all right.
What do you do here?
Uh,
just do what you want to do.
All right.
If you can't live with it,
I would tell her,
if not,
I mean,
you fucking smoke.
You took a hit off a joint.
If you're not going to,
she really committed and you're not going to do it again.
Is it really worth putting you in her through this?
It's kind of hard for me to give you advice here cause I don't know what you
broke up for you.
I mean,
you did it while you were broken up.
It's not like you went out and you bang some other woman.
You just went out and you just took a hit and you didn't fucking do it again.
Um,
and you know,
that's it.
But at the end of the day,
you know something,
if you come clean and she's still breaks up with the over that,
then you know what fucker she,
if she can't accept you,
it's not like you went out and you started using heroin and you stole all the
money out of our fucking purse.
She can't handle one hit of a joint and then you feel bad about it.
And he can't even lie to her about it without fail and terrible and that you
have to tell her.
You tell her that the reason why you didn't tell her it's because you care about
her and you didn't want to lose her.
If she still leaves you after that,
then you know she was going to find something.
Right.
Okay.
Jim Girl,
uh,
you know something.
I don't know if I have time to read all of these.
I,
I gotta I gotta fucking get out of here.
Here be okay.
This is the worst thing ever.
I'm going to try to read this quickly.
I already read bad when I'm reading at a normal pace here.
Hey,
Billy,
cue ball.
A couple of months back,
I started going to another gym,
a town over for a change of scenery.
Uh,
after a couple of weeks I've run into this tall athletic girl.
She didn't talk to anyone and had that,
I'm not trying to talk to anyone.
Look going on because of this,
me and virtually because of what?
Because of this and me virtually never called approaching a girl before I left
her alone.
Over the next few weeks.
I noticed she would be in my area a lot.
And when moving between exercises,
we would cross paths a lot.
Uh,
sounds like you're doing that fucking whatever that workout is.
Crossfit.
Well,
you've got to run down the street.
You know,
look at us,
everybody,
we're working out.
Hey,
look at us,
you know,
leaving your gym and running around and fucking seven 11 parking lot and coming
back we'd get it.
You're working out.
Jesus Christ.
All right.
Over the next few weeks I noticed she would be in my area a lot and when,
all right,
I already said that.
Okay.
Uh,
we crossed paths.
All right.
So,
um,
I said fuck it.
And started talking to her.
We had a couple of good combos and I eventually got a number.
Look at you.
You're in the gang.
We didn't text much,
which is fine because I've learned that texting should be mainly for planning
meetups.
I still try to a couple of techs Convault's for some rapport since,
uh,
I'd only seen it one to three times a week,
sometimes just in passing.
Now,
the issue is every time I've messaged her,
she randomly stops messaging.
They'll probably cause you're bugging her at that point,
no matter how good the conversation was going or she's busy.
Uh,
I didn't see her for a week before I left for vacation,
uh,
for another two weeks and no contact.
It's been a week since I've been back and I haven't seen her in the gym.
Was marginally interested.
Was she marginally interested or did I not come on strong enough?
Should I text her again or just move on and wait til I see her again?
Well if you're still into or just Texas,
just say,
Hey,
I haven't seen yet the gym and what the,
where's the harm in that,
you know,
this day and age,
make sure there's a lawyer there when you're doing thank you.
Cause who knows with the,
uh,
the,
what the next fucking thing is going to be.
Um,
yeah,
I would just,
I would text her and just say,
hey,
you know,
back,
would you like to go out?
Sometimes it gives a fuck,
fuck her and our cold fucking vibe.
Just say what you want to do with that.
She wants to do it.
Go do it.
If she doesn't move on,
that's it.
Easy one.
All right.
But I wouldn't question yourself,
you know,
fuck all that.
Don't be in your head.
Um,
don't be like John Fabro in swingers.
You know?
That's what I always think.
Just never get into that fucking mode.
Just,
uh,
you know,
it's normal to be nervous.
Both men and women when you're dating or whatever.
Men and men,
women and women,
everybody included.
MMM.
Whenever you get into that,
I would say don't ever send a text when you're in that mode.
I would sit down,
relax,
and just think,
what do I want?
I want to go on a date with this person.
Well,
that's what you ask them.
Okay.
I would love to take you out sometimes senior a minute.
I'd love to take you out sometime.
Right?
That's it.
What's she going to say?
How dare you fucking ask me out?
She's either going to say yes or no.
Okay.
And if she says no,
who gives a fuck?
You don't have any regret you asked.
But if you don't ask,
then you've got to be like,
oh,
well you wouldn't have been all right for some gone wrong.
This is the last one and I'm done.
I recently visited my friend at his big time college for his schools,
school rivalry weekend.
MMM.
I'm going big time.
That's what they said when they went to Notre Dame versus a USC and they were
like big time college football.
Uh,
speaking of Notre Dame got a big Tam as kicking against Miami holds shit.
The convicts kicking the shit out of the fucking,
I like that.
It's still called the Catholics and not the pedophiles.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
not everybody at the University of Miami
and has gone to jail or been arrested.
Okay.
But if you're going to call them convicts,
God dammit,
we've got to go pedophile with Notre Dame.
Right.
Um,
it was a great tan and his school was one.
It's school one,
and at the last second and at the last second.
So the atmosphere is crazy.
Later that night,
I attended a party at the fraternity.
He is a member of any wage.
We meet these two girls and decide to tell him we were actually real real life
brothers and we somehow tricked slash convinced these girls into having a
foursome.
How do you tell them that you're related and that they want to do it?
Yeah.
Tricked is a very dangerous world word to use right now,
buddy.
MMM.
All right.
We all go into this room.
Well,
what do you mean trick?
What do you do?
Did you do the old quarter?
Hey,
go make a quarter disappear.
where's the quarters it behind your ear hears my Dick.
Uh,
we all go into his room and start hooking up and since he had a large bed,
we had girls on it and we're banging them side by side.
Doggy style after what seemed like a while,
but was probably six minutes.
I unfortunately released my champagne of victory.
So now it's my buddy and both the girls in the bed and I'm just in the corner of
the room.
I really wanted to come back in there.
Okay.
But I knew it would take a little bit of time to get back up.
So I decided to look for something to use to start jerking off.
Oh.
I found out were turned out to be my buddy's contexts solution and applied it
and started tugging.
After a few minutes Olympic tugging,
I started to feel movement and thought I'd be back in the game soon.
You're like an injured player that went out for a play.
At that moment,
my buddy and the two chicks,
so he was nailing turn around and face me and catch me jerking off.
From their perspective,
they think of jerking off to them.
Oh,
now when in reality I'm jerking it so I can bang the second girl.
One girl sort of freaks out.
I love that she freaks out if they have to fucking thinking that she's having a
fucking force him with two brothers.
One girl sort of freaks out of my buddy's screams,
what the hell are you doing?
Yeah.
At that point I didn't know what to say,
so I ran out of the room naked and just stood outside the door until they
finished.
Eventually the girls left and my buddies,
let my buddy let me back into the room where he proceeded to ask why I was
jerking off to him.
Oh No.
He goes,
I tried to plead my case and give rash and give a rational explanation,
but he's continuing to be persistent that I was jerking off to him and now he's
being extremely distant from me and has told all of our friends who have
constantly been berating me for jerking off while my buddy bang two chicks.
Do you have any advice on how I can somehow spin this story?
I mean,
at the end of the day I did get laid to,
um,
all right,
here's what's hilarious bottle at that the woman gets offended.
Like,
what are you doing?
It's like,
You're having like a fucking force them with two people that you think are
related.
Uh,
and secondly,
I don't know how guys do that.
I don't know how you could bang a woman with your buddy next to you also banging
,
you know what I mean?
Like how do you block out the sound of your friend?
Like right next to you.
I mean,
do you look at each other at any point and like how do you not start fucking
laughing?
I don't,
I've never understood that.
Um,
yeah,
you probably should have gone into the bathroom.
You probably shouldn't have been looking at them.
I mean do what you have here is a fucking hilarious story and I,
you know,
in the spirit of the table,
all right,
when your friends are giving you shit,
I would just laugh.
You just have to learn to laugh at yourself and just be like,
I swear to God I was trying to get back in the fucking game.
Just tell the story the way you just told it to me and think that it's fucking
hilarious that this dude thinks she would jerking off to him.
I would just laugh it off.
Which is how you get out of most shit.
You know,
it's how Donald Trump became president.
He just lets probably a bad guy to bring up who's out there grabbing pussies.
It'd be like you said all this shit about women.
No,
didn't I said it about Rosie O'donnell.
Ah,
well you said it about other women too and he's like,
yeah,
you're probably right.
It ends it.
It's when you keep fighting it.
I would just fucking laugh it off.
I know it's tough at your age,
but listen dude,
if you have it in you to fucking fuck a woman right next to your friend,
if you have the focus to do that,
I think he can get through this.
Um,
but two,
you got it.
One hell of a goddamn story.
That's a great story.
Um,
so anyways,
all right,
that's it.
I have to,
I've got to get on with my day here and thanks to everybody,
uh,
who's listened to the podcast.
Thanks to the Fox Foundation,
the west side comedy club.
Please go.
Please go out to the comedy club and thanks to everybody on front runner,
uh,
that,
let me have a quick little part in that thing.
I had such a great time.
Oh,
and by the way,
guess what's out daddy's home part too.
I was in part one.
You got part two,
I heard is even better.
Joe Barton.
Nick Rosebowl tailgate legend told me he went to go see.
They said,
dude,
I fucking laughed out loud like 25 times.
Comedians don't laugh out loud ever.
It's one of the,
one of the fucking,
I don't know.
It's one of the prices you pay as a comedian.
You stop laughing.
You just start going,
oh,
that was funny.
But you never laugh.
You never laugh again.
So definitely go check that out.
And uh,
who knows?
Who knows?
Maybe you'll see a familiar face in there.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.